hey folks welcome back to the dark horse
podcast live stream 137 qna segment we
are ready to rock and roll indeed we are
i've got disappointing news to start
though oh the discord uh the question
from discord this week assumes that we
know more than we do i don't think we're
prepared to answer it
the question is would you please talk
about the faked alzheimer's research
which i'm just sort of barely aware of i
haven't looked into it and uh they did
send a video as well but i'm just seeing
the question now so we didn't have a
chance to yeah things have been
incredibly busy i'm aware that it
happened i know a little but i couldn't
talk about it either so why don't we uh
look into it and return there
yeah although i don't want to promise
that we're going to uh in the next
in the next month or so when things
remain very very busy so um
maybe uh
you lovely person who sends me these
questions um go ahead and send us two
next week and from discord server and
also include this one until
we we actually get to it all right all
right so that's oh
um
the questions that came in
on darkhurstmissions.com
begin with
this one oh well this is this first one
is not a question well somehow i blinked
and missed something like a year worth
of streams here's 10 or so weeks of
worth of my traditional young man behind
the curtain appreciation tip at least
been busy working on my startup which
you guys might be interested in actually
but i won't hijack this tip note for an
ad that would be rude
nice that's nice thank you
okay next question
first question
love first question that we're going to
answer all right
love freedom and truth are axiomatic to
human civilization they exist in a
relationship similar to pressure
temperature and volume
changing one affects the other two the
problem today with woke ideology is
their attempt to describe love and
freedom while denying the existence of
truth
that's interesting
yeah i might have to think about the so
the three words freedom and truth love
freedom
[Music]
and truth so i guess the prediction of
this would be
that uh if you were to
rank a
society as functional
or you were to rate its durability
that it those things would be
would exist
functionally
throughout the period of viability i'm
not totally sure that's true
but
um right
but anyway and i guess the other i i
think it's interesting
uh it warrants more consideration but
the other thing that i'm not
sure about as framed is
um
the claim that woke ideology attempts to
describe love and freedom while denying
these sense of truth i think
i'm not sure
i'm not sure that they attempt to
describe love or freedom
you know yeah they certainly they may
evoke them yeah they well they they make
a point of saying you know freedom isn't
as important as justice right like they
they
they recognize
without saying so in such explicit terms
i think that there's a trade-off there
um
and you know they use the word love
community love community love love
matters love not hate you know this sort
of thing um but it seems like a really
unloving movement like really not full
of love at all tone deaf humorless and
uh
rather hateful yeah both both hateful
and loveless yeah not the same thing
yeah i agree i see it the same way
um
[Music]
you know and i guess the other thing i
would say is
uh
i have
made the point that
none of the various values that we might
pursue
should be pursued
uh in isolation because of trade-offs
but there's an exception to that which
is
realized liberty which might be
synonymous with freedom in the way
you're using it or it might not you'd
have to answer that question but the
reason
that freedom functions differently
is that it's it is integrative and
therefore requires you to solve the
other
uh issues in a society in order to to
get there so to the extent that you have
lots of choice about how to function
that's because you're not in jeopardy on
all of these other fronts so i guess the
question is if you're arguing that these
things are like three legs of a stool
i'm arguing that actually liberty itself
is a bit like the stool and the legs of
that stool we could debate what they are
but
the point is it uh
it includes them so
this could the difference in our
viewpoints might be the result of the
fact that we are defining things
differently that happens um
or it might be the result of the fact
that they are actually incompatible
models in which case
um
my model challenges your model to a
meeting at the flagpole at three o'clock
which flagpole will leave to your
imagination yeah really any flagpole
will do yeah
okay
why
since the dominance of germ theory have
so many i just say rising exponentially
have so many of the viruses we have
evolved with for millions of years
suddenly become threats
or is virus hunting enabling back
selling a lucrative scam
i would say this is highly complex
yeah so i mean of course you know germ
theory also emerges around the same time
as the industrial revolution as the
exponential rise in population therefore
the density of of uh the way that most
people live
um
transportation
transportation decline in um in many
cases we talk about
increase in quality of food but a lot of
declining quality of food with regard to
taking in a lot more processed stuff
which
affects immune response
indoor living and other things that
block vitamin d production
indoor living doesn't um suddenly
increase greatly around the time of the
germ theory
people were living inside before
industrial revolution well the question
is
by indoor living i'm talking about a
style of living indoors which um
not just sleeping indoors but spending
most of your time indoors more time you
spend indoors
the more the more difficulty you're
going to have i think generating enough
vitamin d presumably being really in no
way a historian but yes that the
industrial revolution effectively if not
created
um
gave serious acceleration to basically
the white collar class the office
workers and and that that would
that would suddenly be a much larger
percentage of time or even even factory
workers or that as well
so for sure so i would say the big
biggest suspects on my list would be
transportation which means that the
population to which any given pathogen
is exposed goes through the roof so what
we're experiencing is something where
it's very difficult to have a pathogen
circulate and burn itself out on
an island on a continent and not reach
the others because people are in moving
between all of these things so regularly
and then our vulnerability as a result
of changes in
diet
density of living and
vitamin d production in particular
yep i would say those are those are all
the
most likely culprits yes that said um
i have thought something along these
lines with regard to um stars kobe 2
with the you know the preposterous will
not die zoonotic origin story for
serious kobe 2. uh and
you know there have been a lot of
versions of the preposterous story hey
you don't sound like me do you
i'm just thinking about the fact that
you're on camera and i'm talking oh that
was weird yeah yeah that was weird that
was the worst ventriloquist act ever
yeah no
oh
yeah anyway right um
it is implausible
uh that
it's beyond implausible that this
particular virus emerged from a cave
right
but
it does seem like it is it is the go-to
explanation for
a certain style of scientist to say well
of course sonatic diseases are going to
be on the rise in part because of some
of the things we talked about just now
population density and transportation
and such but it's also true that yes
it's been not millions but tens of
millions hundreds of millions of years
in some cases that we've been
living side by side and
and
suddenly we have an outbreak and some of
the things of which we have
outbreaks
may actually not be the big deal that we
are told they are and we need to stop
everything and pay attention to them i
don't i don't you know that is not the
case for serious kobe 2 but that also
was not a zonatic outbreak
well i do think
the factors that we listed
increase the vulnerability and therefore
the likelihood of a pandemic but the
nonsense that is being circulated in
order to justify research that is it
turns out extremely reckless yes is uh
preposterous and this has to stop yeah
right yeah um we will return to this in
future
discussions but
no but the degree to which the uh
hyperventilating class
talked us into allowing and then
circumvented a ban on research that
seems to have now released this virus
with all of the havoc that came
downstream
that ought to give us a sense for what
happens when you get a culture of
scientists having to be salesmen in
order to get their research funded we
come up with a really scary story about
viruses leaping out of nature and we boy
we better get ahead of that and of
course you know obtain how is the virus
going to leap out of nature well right
through the laboratory that's how it's
going to happen yeah
um i mean it's also true you know you
referred to scientists having to be
salesmen which is absolutely true
but also included in every grant
application that i've ever seen
you have to you know even if what you're
applying to do is basic research and cut
which is in contrast to applied research
wherein the research is um
this feels worth knowing right there
there is there this this is not research
that is going to inherently be applied
i'm not trying to solve a current
technological problem or military
problem whatever i'm trying to
understand the world that is what basic
research means basic does not mean
simple or we should have known this
already it just means not applied so
i've only ever applied for and
occasionally been in a position to
review grant applications for basic
research and every single one of them
nsf nih like all of the agencies
require that you justify that you
explain what its value will be having
been done which would seem to be at odds
with the idea of it being basic research
and indeed it is
and um having to write that little bit
about what is the utility to human what
can you foresee as the utility to
humanity of doing this research
it's hard not to maybe begin to buy your
own pr a little bit and so
and especially if this becomes the the
kind of research that you do for your
entire career and you start you come to
have a lab and you come to be a pi a
principal investigator on which other
people are
are relying
well that one little paragraph that you
wrote at one point maybe even as a grad
student which has now become the thing
that you repeat and it's your mantra
it's like oh we need to do this research
because psychotic diseases are coming
for us and not diseases are coming for
us
uh you know that claim was just a claim
that claim wasn't ever scientifically
vetted probably yeah and in some cases
it may be but very often it's not
and
that means that a lot of the reasoning
that people are now using to explain why
their research is absolutely necessary
is based not even on faulty science but
no science at all yeah what these are so
uh
i think this is really crucial and i i
worry that people won't understand
exactly what you're getting at but
to the extent that you work in some area
you have a set of you know three
paragraphs you have the elevator
speech set up for why it is necessary
that i study the question that i study
right and it becomes a feature of every
grant application it's something you
review in any public talk that you would
give and it's just like here are the
five sentences that explain why i'm
studying this thing
it is in conflict with the desire and
the value of basic research clearly
um
but
it also does result in this self
um this rationalization process yeah um
and
uh it can't help but be corrosive and
what these things are in order to
function in the way they do they are
plausible but it would be one thing if
they were just simply plausible based on
everything we know but in the case of
for example the story that justified or
pseudo-justified that rationalized our
investigation
our turbocharging of pathogens in order
to study what we would do if a
turbocharged pathogen ever got into the
world right
that basically the point is
these things are plausible in the
limited venue of people who control the
flow of well-being in a particular
discipline
in other words it might well be that if
there were proper evolutionary
biologists in the world in any number
that if you pointed them at the question
of are our zoonotic diseases a giant
looming threat that we have to treat
with the highest urgency they might view
it very differently but if the point is
oh
a bunch of virologists who all of whom
their well-being depends on the sense
that the study of viruses is an urgent
matter
it may be very the three paragraphs may
be very plausible in that audience and
not plausible at all somewhere else and
it doesn't matter
yes
yeah that's an important point
sorry
thoughts on transhumanism
as nature is turned into consumables can
we talk about obligate
humanism
p.s the word transhumanism is absent
from autocorrect dictionaries
um that's probably because the ai feel
threatened by it and therefore refused
to dignify it with an autocorrect
i think yeah maybe what echo is getting
out here this is from echo
i don't know about the term
transhumanism
how do you define it what do you
understand to mean
it is a vague reference to the
exceeding of natural human limitations
right the idea is that we are escaping
the constraints of the body right so
one endpoint for which is imagined to be
the singularity
well the singularity is a different
emphasis the singularity is the point at
which technology technology
self-facilitates at a rate that it
becomes impossible it's a it's a
event horizon you can't see the
consequence of technological progress
beyond some rate of uh self-augmentation
but transhumanism tends to be associated
with things like radical longevity
research
and
on the one hand i i have a couple of
complaints about it just maybe not as a
term but definitely as a as a cultural
orientation
one of them
is
it tends it ignores
the degree to which this is what's
special about humans right humans are
constantly and have for tens of
thousands probably millions of years
been exceeding
their inherited limits
through
the conscious exercise
of
imagination which turns into
niche
that is to say people discover how to do
things that their ancestors couldn't do
all the time and that's not new
to the extent that you think you're
about to escape the body
you are telling yourself a story yeah
it's not true and you're frankly using
it as part of a sales pitch to jump
ahead of other research programs which
might be less exciting but more
promising yes right to give one
particularly poignant example
the quest
for radical longevity extension right on
the one hand what's the harm
doesn't it drive research that at worst
will teach us things about
human physiology that we wouldn't
otherwise have known what's the harm
well the harm is you just jumped ahead
of the program that actually extends
life
right we know how to extend human life
it's not even hard right you reduce
damage to the body right you study
things that actually hurt people you
figure out so you you need to be clear i
know what you're saying i'll get there
yeah but
it's very misleading so far
i don't think so okay my point is if
you're trying to extend the maximum
length that any human being could live
beyond 120 years
right there's no demonstration yet that
we have any capacity to alter that
number what's more if we did alter that
number if we took
and twenty and we said oh we can get you
to a hundred and thirty
well it would suck right we won't have
done anything about the failure of the
mind
and what is certain is that selection
hasn't
pruned us of any of the things any of
the new failures we will discover if we
start reaching those ages what's more
most people don't get to 120 so
extending that final number
is meaningless to almost anybody if
you're going to die at
80 of lung cancer then the fact that you
could in theory live to 150 is
completely meaningless even if it wasn't
going to be a garbage life so there's
lots of stuff that says that's not
liable to be promising
but here's what is promising
human lifespan has gone up
maximum lifespan hasn't budged but
average lifespan has gone radically up
it goes up with things that improve
quality of life quality of the food you
have access to quality of the real
medicine to which you have
access and so the point is look you want
to extend your life stop looking at 120
and saying i i can't get over the fact
that i will never live past that number
no matter what happens and start
realizing you're not going to get to
that number the thing that's going to
increase your chances of getting to that
number are dealing with the pathologies
which we've gotten good at dealing with
and the fact is most of why
we live much longer now is downstream of
two things
one
we've made childbirth safer right so the
average longevity has gone up in part
because the vast number of people used
to be lost
at birth or shortly thereafter has gone
way down but the other thing is we have
decreased damage to the body from all
kinds of things we've figured out how to
treat bacterial and fungi
what do you say when you say we've made
childbirth safer usually what that means
is it's talking about maternal
safety so it's true that there used to
be a lot more deaths of infants and
childbirth but the
but the increase
in um
survival past the age of five is more
about
uh decreasing
uh path like
pathogens and nutritional threats and
things like that yeah yeah it's not it's
not it's not that all these children
were dying in like as they were being
born right it's that a lot of kids are
dying before the age of one
that aren't now that's true and also a
lot of mothers are surprised both things
are true we have increased the survival
of mothers and we have increased the
survival of infants and both of those
things have increased uh average
longevity and yeah this is one of the
things that confuses people and people
say well we didn't used to live past 35
no
nonsense the average was much closer to
that but that's because so many people
were lost you know before they were
one year of age but
anyway point is
beating
bacterial and fungal infections
tremendously increasing of average
longevity
learning how to deal with the
pathogenicity of viruses that is to say
prevent their spread
mitigate their harms once they've been
contracted
all of these things have increased
average human longevity that is a
research program
that you put dollars in and you get
longevity out right the radical
longevity increase that's so focused on
the fact that you're not going to live
to a thousand that is a waste of money
not because if it were the only game in
town it wouldn't produce gains but the
point is the gains you get per dollar
are much smaller than the gains you
would get if you studied the stuff that
is much more proximal yeah so jumping
ahead in the research queue is
um not free
it's very expensive so i'm not thrilled
with transhumanism in part because it
pretends that you know anybody who isn't
into it is somehow unimaginative and
giving up it's like no no there are
things you could do that take that
effort and get you a much higher return
on investment and you are deciding to
gamble on a very likely impossible goal
and you're squandering all that resource
that's that results in people actually
surviving less yes indeed
uh i want to apologize i think that uh
it turns out that your
your hip problem is contagious
and i'm just i'm not feeling very
comfortable at all so this is the space
i'm gonna i'm gonna let you take the
lead on a lot of these questions here
okay this is the nature of hypnosis that
it is contagious it's a fast it's not
it's not it's like that socket is not
doing well okay
i'm naked and afraid a biologist
contestant ate tomatoes prior to being
dropped in the amazon planning to poop
the seeds and grow plants
do you have examples of invasive species
by humans that are helpful or good
um
okay i don't quite get the setup here
i get the tomatoes end up in the amazon
maybe i don't know if it worked i don't
know i don't know enough about tomato
seeds to know if they would survive a
human gut uh some so some seeds wouldn't
right but i mean even so i mean here's
the problem well and also just you know
if if the biologist presumably did his
her sounds about him
his research
um and knew that tomatoes were going to
survive the human gut and was willing to
start through his own poop to get them
um
there's no it doesn't mean that tomatoes
would become invasive is that going to
be your objection here so it doesn't is
so even if
he was successful and he got them to
grow and he was able to eat tomatoes
that doesn't mean that as soon as he
wasn't tending them those tomatoes
wouldn't be out competed by what was
there already yeah they would almost
certainly be right um and so so being
introduced is not the same thing as
being invasive invasive has a like you
know comes to have a life of its own
invasive basically is a synonym for
competitively superior in the given
context yep um
and so you can have
so far
all invasives are introduced
mostly
yeah yeah well i mean i think i think
that's almost circular um that's not
circular it's about it's about
understanding the set nature of the
terms is you know is invasive a
subcategory of introduced well i mean
look let's sort the biology i i think
the terms probably aren't going to be
fleshed out enough that we have a term
for everything we need right certainly
most of how creatures ended up where
they are is going to involve some
creature that wasn't where it is getting
over some mountain into some habitat and
it doesn't have to have involved any
well that's that's the dispersal
explanation or vicarian events could
have happened such that the animal
passively was moved by its land mass or
its current but the point is is it an
invasive if i'm growing it on this side
of a mountain and it finds its way to
that side of the mountain is it an
invasive well if it grew here naturally
you can make an argument i don't think
the biology is obvious the
meaning of whether the term applies is
irrelevant
i think you're not understanding my
attempt to categorize the terms but um
it's not the main thing here okay well
anyway here's the thing about tropical
forests tropical forests mature mainland
tropical forests
are
incredibly resistant to invasion okay in
fact i believe this fact is still true
there is no case
of a canopy tree from one place in the
world
invading a tropical mainland mature
tropical habitat
anywhere else in the world
that's not because people haven't
behaved stupidly with these things it's
because the creatures that are there are
so
ferociously competitive and well adapted
to their environment that the
opportunity
to go from in one individual to many
individuals is almost non-existent
okay that'll be a little less true for
things that aren't canopy trees but the
basic principle holds these habitats are
very resistant to invasion what about
hawaii well what is it about canopy
trees do you think
uh what is it
uh it's just a fascinating little aside
like oh canopy tree is more than
epiphytes more than understory
plant smart like because you can imagine
a disturbance regime for other things
that would open some opportunity for
which there wasn't a
uh a dominant competitor because the
opportunity was ephemeral enough okay um
something like that but anyway the point
is the general principle holds
what about hawaii
what about galapagos what about jamaica
what about all the places where you've
seen
uh tropical invasions well they're all
islands and the reason that the islands
are special
is that islands have reduced numbers of
species and i also argued in my
dissertation that they have reduced
intensity of competition because things
that are there have been favored for
dispersal characteristics rather than
competitive ferociousness
so bottom line is
it's hard to introduce something
to the amazon that would stick yeah
right could you grow tomatoes there yeah
but you'd probably have to do two things
protect them from competition and enrich
the soil
right tropical soils tend to be poor the
argument i made in my dissertation was
that they're poor because the creatures
that grow on them are so good at
competing that they basically
extract them all of the nutrients are
stuck in the plants not in the in the
soil and so the soils underneath are
very poor
so all the nutrients living in like a
seedling bank
uh
they're all somewhere circulating in the
biota as opposed to in the supposedly
abiotic soil which of course is also my
eye right yeah but there just isn't this
thick layer of stuff in fact
get the cat off the keyboard
the cat apparently almost stopped the
stream all right i'm going to
yeah all right i i think he just wants
attention and if the stream ends he'll
probably get more of it some of it will
be negative attention at this point but
okay so
invasions are a problem
in particular habitats and i would argue
between particular pairs of habitats
where one habitat is in a predic a
situation where it can generate
successful competitors for an
environment elsewhere right
um
so the chances in the in that case you
uh you argue for are low in the parts of
the world that are vulnerable to
invasion this is
an absolute disaster right but the
question is do you have any examples of
invasive species that are yes positive
well i can come up with a couple trivial
ones because we can we can come up with
yes so many that are that are not
they're obviously not and that are in
obviously not uh but you so i don't
actually i can't come up with any
examples aside from
yeah they're positive go for it well
they're positive but the invasive aspect
of them probably is irrelevant so a fox
glove
creates digitalis which is a very useful
heart drug fox glove is invasive in the
pacific northwest
right we have it all over the place um
it's a very successful invasive in part
because things like deer can't eat it
and it does technically is the source of
this art drug but i don't think they're
collecting it on the side of the road to
make digitalis undoubtedly they're
making it i don't know what it's
displacing you know it's pretty right
but i don't know what it's displacing
undoubtedly it may be seven things it
may be slightly displacing seven things
it may be fully displacing something
yeah um
let's see
uh so i feel like with you know we don't
i would like an ecosystem level analysis
of you know this is actually good
at like the ecosystem level good for the
ecosystem which you know i don't that
kind of thinking is is a little dicey
but
um
i don't
it's quite possible that someone who
imagines himself like a landscape
ecologist or a conservation biologist
has attempted to do such an analysis but
i don't know well i waited on such
research yeah
bees
which bee is honeybees
hmm
honeybees are invasives from asia
and
all the apis or apus
the honey honeybee okay which also
has become africanized in some
populations same species right same
species now
so here's the problem it's beneficial
highly beneficial yeah arguably
it is now naturalized more than arguably
yeah i mean when did this happen given
that we hear about how many crops are
reliant on honeybees well the question
is
is what honeybees displaced
um the pollinator of
you know put crops aside for a second if
the diagnosis for this the question of
whether they're they are or not positive
is whether or not the
job that they're doing is positive then
the question is is that job is there
more of that job being done yeah
but i'm just wondering about the story
given like okay well what was doing all
the pollinating before
uh yeah undoubtedly other insects
well sure but that's not a complete
story no but but really the point is the
question is asking for a net answer that
we can't give but i'm saying that i
don't i'm not sure i believe the story
until i get a little bit more detail
okay yeah
uh if if true yes honeybee is cool
answer
yep yeah um let's think
if there are any others
i don't i don't have anything yep
i'm sure given a little a little time
we can come up with something but uh
well the only other cases would be
things like
not the only other cases the obvious
other cases are cases where something
was introduced
to control
a third introduced thing or a second
introduced thing yeah which are often
failures yes
yes and then i mean of course you have
you know you you have all the
domesticates
uh which have pluses and minuses
all of them hear that
yeah you can't hear me he's too busy
making himself pretty yeah
all right
next question
are high intensity exercises like squat
jumps and burpees healthy or are they
trading cardiovascular fitness now for
joint issues later in life
how about running
um
it's gonna vary yeah it is gonna vary
and you know there's obviously there's
cardiovascular stuff you can do that is
less um
less joint involved
um you know biking versus running is the
thing that we used to talk about a lot
like you know at 40 um i briefly ish
it's like no maybe i should start
running like why would i start running
now when i bike when i can you know i
can get farther yeah i could go faster
and i could put no stress on my joints
um but yeah squat jumps and burpees i i
wonder i wonder we have we have friends
who are very very fit
uh who swear by uh
things like this and you and i both do
them sometimes but
you got to be more and more careful the
older you get and the longer it's been
since you did anything like that yeah
and uh and i and i do
wonder about the
i wonder about the actual story on wear
and tear on ligaments and tendons having
you know
i had occasion to think about it a lot
after i erected my achilles my left
achilles in
2015
um
which was almost certainly as every
doctor i've talked to about it
facilitated by uh pharmaceuticals that i
had taken earlier in life the um
cipro ciprofl the fluvoxamines i think
is the is the antibiotic class i may
have made that up no that's wrong yeah
that's right just cipro is the clear one
i don't know what the yeah it's an it's
in a class of
i can't report the classes um
but you know okay so
cipro and its other its related
antibiotics are now known
to uh to promote
joint injury to promote
linden
tendon and ligament damage both acutely
when you're on the thing and it's
somehow
additive the more
of these doses you've been on in your
life
but that raises the question of what
normal wear and tear would look like
what you know what you know muscle
rebuilds the story is that things like
cartilage doesn't but my sense and
having talked to a few health
professionals who i trust also said no
actually sometimes cartilage does grow
back like a
you know meniscus tear in the knee for
instance
uh so and that's but then then with
these like tendons ligaments you know
partially vascularized vascularized in
some places not others like what is the
wear and tear and like what
i i don't know how to arrive at the
right answer here
well the right answer is a framework
which is yes
there are trade-offs in all of these
things can you do a burpee without some
wear and tear on your joints absolutely
not it's inconceivable so there will be
some wear and tear
would you be better off with no cardio
nope
um so the real question is what is the
optimal balance between these things
with respect to what's actually going to
slow you down in the end what's actually
going to reduce your capacity to do
things and
a balanced approach is almost certainly
better than focusing on one thing that's
good i mean you know look
uh
you have an amount
of maintenance and repair capacity based
in
telomeres of the tissues in question
built for an average life
if you take a job in which you keep
damaging one tissue again and again and
again because you're driving spikes in a
railroad and the point is you're going
to age there faster than everything else
right so you don't want to do that what
you want to do is distribute the damage
across your tissues so that they all age
at the same rate
and you know overly focusing on anything
is not good that said
your ancestors didn't have bicycles you
can reduce you can get a certain amount
of cardio without doing damage to your
tissues because this mechanical thing
solves that problem yes
but don't fall off
yeah suddenly suddenly suddenly the
damage is acute and all over
yeah it's definitely don't fall off as
my new bicycling priority
good
okay
uh given heather's love of indices
and the variety of topics you cover what
if darkhorse fans crowdsource an index
of topics in the episodes in which they
appear
i think i do have a love of indices i
hadn't thought of that but uh thought of
it in those terms
um
i would i would love such a thing i'm
just pleased as punch to hear this
described as indices rather than indexes
that always strikes me as wrong yeah
there will there will be those who will
insist on indexes
um
yeah or appendices versus appendixes
okay all right sorry
um this is not a topic that will be
popular amongst our audience it will
show up very low in the index
index isn't going to be a topic that's
popular with you which is why you are
now talking about other things sorry i
have straight
i like the idea very much um but there's
not much more to say about it um except
that brett doesn't want to talk about it
but i like it i like the idea i like it
too i know i think it would be very
useful um i go look at him like i know i
know we talked about a thing and i keep
i keep notes ish um but it's not
complete and uh and it would be it would
be great to have such a thing
i this is just a recommendation i am
sure that you are familiar with the
greatest show on earth by richard
dawkins but i bet you didn't know
there's a song inspired by the book i
recommend this to all interested in the
development of our universe and there's
a youtube link i didn't know that
i didn't either okay
i hope it's as good as the uh the
universe song in monty python
uh
what's the name of the monty python um
movie
their last one i think i've forgotten it
anyway
i i don't know the order of the money
python movies i don't yet know what
we're talking about
uh do other animals cuddle with their
mates or offspring is it only mammals
some birds do
birds will snuggle in
um
especially the
juvenile birds together and then parents
with birds if they've been sitting on
nests after they hatch they'll snuggle
in together
um
i don't know if any non-endothermic yeah
that's the question is how much it feels
like this is going to be an endothermic
thing it takes on a meaning beyond
endothermic but it probably starts with
endothermy yeah that's that's
that's going to be the prediction here
yeah birds and mammals not being each
other's closest relatives um but having
a ton in common convergently including
endothermic and fort chambered hearts
and uh and various um
various other things most of which i've
forgotten at the moment but uh um
actually that reminds me
uh there was a question down here
is it weird to ask about tongue
evolution
did they evolve early on and why such
versatile uses for instance cats dogs
people and chameleons
and i thought i used to talk about tons
so i searched on tongues on my computer
and i found this
zachary
this is a slide from a lecturer used to
give on the origin of tetrapods
life on land feeding
water currents can be used to manipulate
food in the mouth actinopterygians
that's refined fish like salmon and
mudskippers are great at this but this
isn't possible in the air so food
manipulation in tetrapods is usually
accomplished with a
fleshy muscularized tongue
this is it is imagined and then there's
also i think
here we go i also found this
which is some of the research excuse me
um
that i used for this little tiny piece
of this lecture on the evolution of
tetrapods
a review from 2002 called the evolution
of the structure and function of the
vertebrate tongue and iwasaki here the
author of this paper also talks about
basically you don't need when you're in
water
to have something in your mouth that is
muscularized by which you're moving food
around because you can use water
currents or you can make your own water
current by moving yourself through the
water to do that to get the food where
it needs to go that is completely
fascinating yeah so this is like this
was one of my favorite lectures that i
that i created and that i used to get
like what are all the things that you
suddenly have to solve once you've moved
to land yeah and one of the things is
once you've got food into your mouth how
do you get it where it needs to go
within your mouth like to your choppers
and back into your throat like you use
your tongue
so this is this is a life on land
solution
how if i miss that it's totally as
it fits yeah it totally it totally fits
the tongue appears to be a not a
vertebrate
uh
snap morphe i mean like some actin
operations have like a little protrusion
but it's not dense doesn't tend to be
muscularized it's not very big and then
at the point you got tetrapods you've
got all these crazy
um
crazy new things going on like frogs
um
[Music]
gosh i think it's all frogs but maybe
it's just the frogs with which i am most
familiar the tongues are connected at
the front of their mouths
and so they flip them out
i know it's ridiculous
it's unholy it's it's unholy and then
let's see is it um
is it
woodpeckers
that it's like
it's wrapped around the back of their
skull
uh and then they can
i could i could look up woodpeckers here
too and see if i have a woodpecker image
i probably do um
and whatever let's you you just keep
talking about tongues if you will i'm
gonna say hey i'm wondering so there are
a lot of aquatic creatures that are
secondarily aquatic that have returned
to the sea and i am betting based on
what you have just informed me of then
they spend a lot of their time sticking
their tongues at
the prime the uh fundamentally primarily
aquatic creatures who cannot stick their
tongues back out i would imagine that
happens a lot i think that's happening
all the time
yep all the time yeah um i probably i
gave i had so many different versions of
verdict evolution and
i'm oh
no we got cranial kinesis
yeah i'm gonna have to think about this
more i would cranial can it sounds like
you're speaking in tongues
um cranial kinesis no i got it i know
what it is you got it i know i know you
guys are crazy so cranial's head kinesis
kinetic means movement so there are a
lot of different evolutions of the head
bones the various head bones moving
relative to one another and so
uh when you hear things like oh my god
that snake can literally unhinge its jaw
like now they don't unhinge their jaw in
order to you know eat something bigger
than it said but they have a
joint that is an addition to our joint
and so they can get a gap that's bigger
than we would be able to given um where
uh the two main pieces of the jaw the
upper and lower jaw are actually
attached
so and then i would i would love to do a
revolution again i wouldn't have to
teach that again
this all raises a question though yeah
um the uh
the phrase he she or it has become
unhinged is that a reference to snakes
do you think um probably yeah yeah i
think it probably is
except
actually i think it's a reference to a
door flapping in the wind or something
yeah no i i think that's actually it but
it'd be better if it was a reference to
snakes yeah um so yeah then the rest of
the question about tongues which
obviously i could spend a lot of time
talking about um why such versatile use
and with yeah i have a hard time
actually i can i can i can talk with my
fingers too
yeah yeah that's spreading yeah that is
great uh why such versatile uses cats
dog peep dogs people chameleons well
given that we now know that this is uh
really a tetrapod synapomorphy being a
characteristic that was derived at the
origin of tetrapods and um and shared
among them then you start to see
diversification and so um
you know frogs with their tongues
attached in the front
at least some frogs uh chameleons
uh with the curled up tongue that then
can be sort of like unfurled like a one
of those like what it looks like party
party popper things
but those have a name they yeah it's not
a popper it's i don't know what they're
called
exactly but that's kind of what um i
somewhere on this computer too i have a
slow-motion video of chameleons hunting
with their
that our friend brad moon gave me at one
point
um he was a much
much better herpetologist than i am and
so of course he has slow motion videos
of chameleon tongues christmas does yeah
as one does
um
so really it's just about
diversification once you know
fit in the tongue fits the job and
giving the tongue originally is about
being able to move food around in
the mouth once you're in air where the
air that can't help you whereas the
water could uh now they're also you know
you can use it if you're one of these
guys one of these epic tabbies uh to
clean yourself or to lick the vitamin d
off your fur apparently vitamin df
you're from
explanation than cleaning themselves i
think it's both
probably a bit of both yeah um but
there's also navigation
oh
yes okay
the fork and tongue of the snake oh and
the vomero nasal organ and the fact that
these
actually first yes yes
the molecules in front of it in two
different directions hence the
forkedness of the tongue and figures out
which way to go based on which direction
tastes right yes yes so you might what
what you all should have been wondering
is if there's a use for two eyes by
which we can get information from two
slightly different places and thus get
depth perception and there's a use for
two ears
by which sound is coming in at two
slightly different places by which we
can get sound perce depth perception
sound and two nostrils why not two tons
so
we don't have them and indeed i think uh
birds no birds do no endotherms do
i think no species wide endothermicity
of course anomalies um but and i don't
think the non-snake squamates do any of
them yeah
[Music]
well maybe
maybe
um
but uh yeah snakes snakes use the two
tips of the tongue to triangulate odors
and to get a sense of direction then yes
they can have they don't i don't think
they don't i don't think we think that
they
navigate across landscapes doing this
but they sort of they follow scent
profiles towards prey they don't like
they're it's not about oh i'm trying to
get home get into the movies
although i don't know i don't know
yeah it's possibly just for lack of i'll
bet that i bet that happens some given
yeah given that the the
basics are there but yeah the fork and
tongue nice does this and uh
this is also the origin of the
expression
his viewpoint is all forked up
is it yes yes yes and it's always his
isn't it
often often yeah
all right um also is it weird to ask
about tongue evolution no no not at all
not in this household not this household
okay
um hive insects how do they evolve
understanding to do collective tasks
there's actually a lot of interesting
thinking on this not done by the hive
insects themselves we don't know i we
presume yes we do presume and um
one thing that is clear is that at least
much if not all of the behavior is uh
requires no understanding per se it
requires an individual to identify a
thing that needs to be done and to have
individuals that are like that first
individual to follow along
so
the question though is how does it
evolve which i think is a great question
um
well it's how do they evolve
understanding so i guess if i if we take
out the word understanding there then
the question how do they evolve the
thing that functions in lieu of
understanding yeah so imagine the
following thing
uh let's take army ants
so army ants are fascinating they move
their hives they have a bivouac place
where they put the hive for some period
of time
and they forage from it
and
as the animals move across space
they sometimes have to do something like
cross a little rivulet of water
right so one of the ways that they do
this is they create a bridge made of
ants
now you can imagine ants that are
quote unquote trying to go in a
particular direction
sort of
maneuvering around the shore finding a
place where there's a little inlet of
rock that goes in and finding the place
that's closest to a cross
and then you can imagine other ants
walking across the back of ants because
ants do that kind of thing and so the
point is a certain amount of this
behavior of just like well maybe if we
keep doing things and evaluating our
progress based on going in that
direction
um we'll find a way that that actually
naturally leads to a bridge-like
phenomenon and so the point is anything
genetically that predisposes ants to do
things that result in the building of
bridge-like structures
gets uh augmented because those hives
that do it
uh or those colonies that do it have an
advantage over colonies that can't cross
that kind of body of water so yep this
is another case like we discussed in the
main podcast
where the slope there's no
adaptive valley there's a gentle slope
that goes from not being able to build a
bridge to being able to build an
elaborate bridge because the more you
can do to build bridges the longer a
body of water you can cross the better
off your hive is there's no
uh
there's nothing that has to be
disassembled to get there just an
elaboration of what's already present
yes
uh so i was just hoping i could quickly
find an image um
but i was not able to find it there's
screaming happening outside yeah
somebody did screen didn't sound like
they were in well danger no it just
sounded sort of mildly enthusiastic yeah
all right yeah i endorsed their mild
um
the story i was going to tell
possible we are going to have to
i don't know you keep talking i'm going
to keep an eye on the situation okay
um
there's a story that we report a
scientific story that we report in the
uh
in the book hunter gatherer's guide to
the 21st century
issue averted whatever that was i think
so yes he may be screaming but we can't
hear him yes the screamer has driven off
okay
um there is a scientific story that we
report in hunter-gatherer's guide and i
don't remember the details at the moment
but somewhere in the research i have a
cool picture
in which a species of ant i don't
remember which one it is
uh
does the thing where they you know have
a nest
and they go out and find food and they
go out in all these directions and then
at the point that someone finds food
they come back and they report out in
whatever way that they do often by
pheromones
uh but
uh you know report that i found food how
do
how do the ants that weren't the ones
that found the food get to the source
that they now know where to go back and
forth to
well uh very often in this case and
again i have to have to look up our
particular the particular example that
we use here
uh
the aunt who first found it could just
lead the way but what they actually tend
to do is they hoist the ant the naive
ant on their back and they just carry
them out there
and then they're there and they've
gotten there and once they've gotten
there then they drop them and now they
know how to get back
and this is apparently uh much more
efficient than having them sort of
follow along like come on now come with
me
they just hoist them and they carry them
upside down and they get them there and
uh then they know what they're doing
yeah that's wild yeah i think
increasingly this is how people should
function
just just let me carry you yeah yeah
all right um
sorry i think we were both thrown by
whatever just happened outside of our
window i'm not sure what it was yeah
most
democratic politicians seem allergic to
investigating lab leak attacks on
attacks on reapers
let's start again most democratic
politicians seem allergic to
investigating lab leak attacks on
repurposed drugs vaccine fail lockdown
which occurred under trump fraudulent
science from the cdc resignations of the
fda etc why
only johnson and paul seem to care
yeah this is an easy one unfortunately
even though some of the stuff like even
though if they if they wanted to play a
political game they could blame trump
for a bunch of this even though that's
not it wouldn't be legitimate right but
like
these vaccines are trumps they were
totally developed under trump right if
if a president gets to take
responsibility yeah gets to house do
whatever right the problem is it seems
like if if they wanted to play the
politics to investigate this stuff they
could yeah but there's a there's a
there's a
a bigger game
that is
preventing that from happening
if you were to follow any of these
threads the whole damn sweater would
come apart right you just pull on it the
whole sweater comes apart right like
what are you going to do you oh my
goodness the the vaccines are creating
uh
lots of adverse events well who decided
to give them to people who get no
benefit for them right all of these
things are going to lead to the
discovery that something has hijacked
your democracy
and plugged it into the market and that
you
um
the voter the citizen
have been betrayed by your government
which above all else must prevent you
from understanding the depth to which
the entire system has been turned
against you by economic capture right so
yep
the reason that they don't investigate
these things is they have a good thing
going and they do not want their racket
understood because if you understood it
you would
not
play your role as
subservient
compliant
citizen yep
oh i'm afraid i'm afraid you're right
uh i'm afraid i'm right too yeah so
we went long the first hour the first
first almost two hours uh so i'm gonna
try to stick to an hour here we only
have a couple minutes left let's get
through as many more of these questions
as we can shall we do it is the usa
mainstream media for its citizens or for
the rest of the world i'm going to read
that again with the right cadence is the
usa mainstream media for its citizens or
for the rest of the world is the
ubiquity of wokism a memetic strategy to
destabilize enemy nations targeting
youth is coveted news used to protect
the us image and relevance
that is a really interesting question if
i get it correctly it's a series of
questions all of which are sort of about
the same thing nobody who matters
pays attention to american american
media in america
right we have a wide diversity of ways
that we reject it
but
the point is are there people who watch
cnn
yes but they're irrelevant they're not
party to any important conversation so
that those channels do seem to be
talking about power brokers
well i'm going to borrow some
terminology here there's this
terminology that's used in uh tech
circles about live players
live players are players that have
enough power to make a meaningful move
that changes something
right elon musk is an obviously live
player
no if we now take that term and apply it
to people right there are people who
have no power in the world to affect
anything they don't
they influence anyone they don't affect
policy
they don't make decisions that are
significant some of them watch cnn
does anybody who matters
put enough stock in what gets said on
cnn
uh that it can
the messaging there no nobody does and
nobody presumably nobody who has a mind
can tolerate npr for more than five
minutes
so the point is the media does seem a
bit paradoxical
it's message matches the message of at
least for the moment the blue team
um but does not appear
it's like a you know
a station that
broadcasts into the abyss
but it doesn't
that's not necessarily how it reads
abroad
so i don't know that i believe that this
is the right answer but i think it is at
least worth investigating the hypothesis
that what we
seemingly incidentally broadcast to the
rest of the world is actually the point
of the exercise
right that if you're not
an american with the ability to
calibrate that nobody's paying attention
to cnn and you see that americans are
receiving this message on one of their
biggest
uh
news stations that may well have an
effect that would be valuable well
i think it's a fascinating question but
i do think you're conflating two two
things here
obviously
many many people pay attention to cnn
when you're talking about
other nation states are you talking
about the live players in other nation
states being confused and therefore
paying attention
because if not then why don't that's you
know
you know either we're talking about what
you're calling live players in the us
and live players in other countries or
we're talking about not i don't know
what the alternative to live players is
but you know the vast majority of people
you know half the country-ish
gets their news from
cnn
npr msnbc
you know washington post new york times
i don't believe that none of those
people are live players
but i also don't quite understand what
you're
what you're imagining about what the
other kind like is this being
communicated potentially if this
hypothesis
is
if the media is actually at some level
for the rest of the world what part of
the rest of the world is it the is the
populous
like the half-ish of american citizens
who watch it in the rest of the world or
is it the people in power
well in the rest of the world i'm not
sure it has to be one or the other
because really the point but you made
the distinction for the us right
my point about the rest of the world is
the rest of the world having a wrong
impression about the conversation
americans are having with themselves
could very well be powerful in shaping
policy that matters to whoever decides
what to program but i think but but if
it's about americans having
conversations with one another then
there are a lot of people who pay
attention to cnn so it's not you know i
don't know what you mean
i don't know anybody who matters who
thinks cnn is associated so the who
matters thing is gonna is very dicey
you're at one level talking about you
know the populace and then you're saying
well the populace doesn't matter
let's talk about loudly for a second
okay
there was a point
at which
any thinking person would be embarrassed
to
uh pretend that the lab leak was not a
viable explanation and most of the
sophisticated people believed it was the
most probable explanation that's very
dangerous if you're trying to prevent
the idea that oh my goodness this lab
thing has suddenly
done a good deal of damage to the world
and the world's nations are now going to
get together and decide what to do about
preventing it from happening again
getting to the bottom of it whatever
but if you can effectively drown out the
ground up grassroots sophistication that
emerged where the american public got
over the lives they were being told
and you can
give the impression that americans are
still by and large in favor of that
natural origin hypothesis then you may
blunt the rest of the world's enthusiasm
for pursuing this at all now does that
happen because the population in germany
is confused does that happen because the
german sophisticates and power players
are confused or some combination
my point is just that there's some value
to misleading the world as to what
conversation we're having
and that that is all too easy to do in
this case especially you've got a bunch
of channels that have lost their
fundamental purpose right they don't
have high engagement
but
if they are understood to be the high
engagement channels in places where you
can't check that
that conclusion then that could be
incredibly valuable and it's certainly
worth asking
i agree with all of that i think i
disagree with your assessment that
just no one in the us is paying
attention to these channels anymore
people who matter are sick of getting
burned
and so you know
who
if you're a person
whose time is valuable because you
actually have opportunity to change
things in the world who wants to tune
into npr and be berated over your you
know not having done enough about racism
you know every seven minutes
right it's a waste of your time and the
point is it's one thing to you know to
say those things at a cocktail party
because you have to or because you feel
it's a good thing to do it's another
thing to waste your own freaking time
listening to that garbage
right and so the i love that built into
that is the idea that when you're at a
cocktail party you're not on your own
time you're not gonna
that's how i feel but i i think that
there are people out there who enjoy
cocktails well they may enjoy cocktail
parties and they may enjoy this social
but the point is there's opportunity the
cocktail party that's why people go to
him right
and
so the fact that people might say things
that suggest that they are deeply i mean
they might even listen to a certain
amount of npr so that they can say at a
cocktail party you know i was listening
to npr but there's a question that once
you've gotten the message that there's
basically one perspective it's
constantly being broadcast and it hasn't
changed for the last three years
then the point is well
i'm not gonna waste my own time maybe
you know maybe take up another hobby or
something so
um another hobby as opposed to listening
to npr well frankly it used to be a big
deal for a lot of us because there's a
lot of value that you can no i guess
given the amount of time yeah maybe it
did count as a hobby it was kind of a
hobby right i mean it wasn't the tote
bags i'll tell you that much no never
did get a tote bag yeah either but
anyway i want to just point out an uh
i like this hypothesis it needs a test i
want to give an example of something
that functions like it
it used to be my understanding as
somebody who grew up in la as you did
that sometimes
the
billboards on sunset boulevard weren't
really for the public they were really
for the celebrities that were pictured
giving them the impression that they
were making it that they were getting
somewhere had some role that it played
in hollywood that wasn't really about
the billboard causing more people to go
see a movie or something like that
i'm not saying that that happened a lot
i i thought it was understood that
sometimes it was sort of within within a
hollywood culture not necessarily for
the person on the billboard but to you
know to pitch to agents to get to you
know someone who's in a running for a
role that may that may well be that's a
better explanation yeah here's another
one that we know worked like this
ads on television and elsewhere that
were really targeted at a particular
legislator or a few of them right if
there was you know hundreds of millions
of dollars at stake in some question
delivering them an ad that would show up
in their sunday paper that looked like
it was directed to the public but was
really directed at you know
you know senator whoever
um
that there was an obvious explanation
for it and so that's the question is
have these channels been repurposed for
something like that where the purpose is
really abroad and so we miss it yep
okay we did a terrible job of
getting quickly through questions and
we're now at an hour but i want to
try to get through a couple more yep
regarding brett's sick pain threshold
idea my first question is what
interaction does fever heat have with
inflammation and does
and does that have with the threshold
effect and with joint pain
i mean i think i think heat does cause
tissue to expand
so fever may cause inflammation
well okay so first of all we can test
that hypothesis not on me
fair enough
you didn't have to back off i just like
you're not going to induce a fever in me
right now no no no
but here's the thing
if it is true that heat
increases the volume of tissue causes
them to expand and fever is a body-wide
phenomenon then it must be that it is
causing you to take on water and we
should be able to detect that with a
scale
let's do it again okay
let's say this i was i was just going
like okay well pv equals an rt so if
temperature if temperature goes up
volume goes up well but
water does not expand right but yeah
you're
we're not all water
all right mostly water all and mostly
are not the same thing
you may have noticed yes
all right
cells can expand cells can well cells
can expand cells can swell edema is real
and actually edema is probably is in
inter cellular well we can still test
this right it's going to be a bit more
painful because we're going to need to
take some tissue and see if this is
again not on me right no
believe me
go for it not not
so the question is why we're not doctors
right
um i think again we're doing a poor job
of getting quickly through these but
nonetheless the point is if the
hypothesis is
well somewhere in here there was a
hypothesis that heat is causing tissues
to expand yeah i am arguing that
expansion
most naturally and maybe obligately
requires the taking on of more water
which is possible i mean look maybe this
is the reason that fluids are understood
to be important if you
stick with a fever maybe you need to
take them well i mean i guess unless
if it's if it's body-wide inflammation
if it's not body-wide then you can
borrow from one place
which would be my expectation except for
the point that as far as i know the
fever is body-wide
right um
so actually it does raise the question
of why fevers are body wide yeah it
might be an organ that we could be like
a heat sink or heat source and i i would
predict it right now that you'll you you
can have a fever in a particular tissue
where you're saying whereas the rest of
you oh yeah you can go on like this
yeah you need to get off the air i need
to get off the damn air but uh i need to
keep breathing here that's not what we
mean by get off the air but uh
yeah
um
but anyway uh so if it were true
that uh a body-wide fever causes
expansion of the tissues because you
have general inflammation then that
would result that would be the result of
taking on more water which we should be
able to detect by just comparing your
your mass
when you are when you do have a feed
room when you don't yep
interesting
good okay
uh recently watched a video talking
about the toxicity of various oils made
from corn seeds nut soy etc what's your
take on them here's a video
uh yeah see seed oils are bad for you
it's the short version of that and uh we
should spend more time on it's actually
hard seed oils are bad for you seed oils
are bad for you they're better for you
than starvation
yes
exactly but that's pretty much
it avoid seed oils unless you're going
to starve if you can't and then don't
and then don't avoid them yeah and then
once you have other options get off the
seed oils yeah we you know we
we eat seed oils we don't cook with them
we don't we don't cook with any seed
oils but there's we aren't perfect about
this right right
but for instance you know potato chips
are not good for you but they are
delicious if you have an option to get
potato chips with avocado oil or olive
oil as opposed to the usuals like
safflower sunflower do that so am i
right am i right that avocado oil is
it's from the
flesh of the avocados not the seed yeah
and i actually made this mistake a while
back and someone corrected me so olive
and avocado are not seed oils
wow makes sense the two oil the two
exceptional fruits the oily fruits right
exactly
oh
three more
and then we will have to skip the rest
of these i apologize vertasium recently
made a video about the inventor of
leaded gasoline and freon
what other common substances do we
naively use at a global scale that might
be just as toxic
so many
well it's hard to get as toxic as
tetraethyl lead
the stuff they put in gasoline yeah that
was
an
extraordinary error i think i probably
talked about it a few weeks back but um
anyway look into that story maybe
eurotassium is a great channel it's
quite possible they did an extraordinary
video on it but yeah
um
what other errors yeah the the what are
you know
glyphosate glyphosate is it generally
what are the air what other what other
common substances
do we naively use at a global scale that
might be just as toxic
yeah
you know all the the
the hormone mimics the estrogen um
the phytoestrogens
or not not the phytoestrogens but they
have the
the estrogens and estrogen precursors
that are dropping into our water supply
that's not going to be as toxic here's
what i want it's going to be confusing
to people uh when they ingest it and
they don't know why they feel the way
they do uh glyphosate i think is is the
best is the easiest one to come to mind
here that's a huge one yeah here's one i
wondered about i don't know for sure
that it's worse than the alternative
but synthetic
motor oil which is great for your engine
and therefore quite good for the
environment at the level of preserving
engines and reducing the amount of
energy that goes into manufacturing them
and things like that however
i will bet you
that nobody has tested the question of
what happens when you take that
synthetic stuff
and burn it what the compounds that are
created are and what the
inhaling of them does which is what
happens when the certain amount of oil
that coats the insides of your cylinders
gets burned and then it comes out the
tailpipe so we're all breathing a lot of
that stuff and who knows what's
downstream of that yeah
i feel like we're missing a ton of
answers to this question we are we'd
love to come back let's put it this way
if we come back to it we should broaden
it because substances is too narrow yep
no i mean i feel like this is this is a
topic for an
awesome book because it's about hyper
novelty right and you know it is it's
something that we touch on in several
places in hunter gatherer's guide but um
not
not in sort of an organized fashion
um
when does a joke become a dad joke when
it becomes apparent
oh
terrible
finally how do we ever reconcile with
those who turned their back on the
vaccine injured
um
the ones who willingly did it i don't
know what we do with those folks that's
uh that is a level of indifference to
human suffering that
shocks me every time i think about it i
would say many people turned their backs
on the vaccine injured as a result of
the fact that they themselves were
misled about what was going on and
that's i feel very differently yeah
about people who did not do this
willingly yep
yep again a question perhaps for another
time but uh
i think that's the right dichotomy yeah
yeah that's right
all right guys we've been here a while
today we have brett has survived i
at least so far yep as have i as his
fairfax he was curled up very nicely
here
having survived the screaming out the
window um
anything else to say um
no it's time for me to get off the air
get off the continuing to
to bring that
air indeed indeed so we will be back
same time next week we will actually be
gone the week after that uh because our
producer has an appointment in a far
away place
which we will perhaps talk about after
he is back indeed
but we will be back here
next week
and in the meantime we encourage you to
be good to the ones you love
eat good food and get outside be well
everyone
[Music]
[Music]
you